Everyone, thanks for coming to the farthest back room of the
convention center to
watch us here in the dark. But we're excited to be here for
our session on
implementation science approaches to advancing
equitable cancer prevention and control.
There is an echo that we cannot...
We won't be able to
Yeah.
You can't hear the echo out there?
It was there in the last session. You were saying last-
It was.
How about... Oh, you were. Oh, you know what? Just step back.
I have some great colleagues presenting
with me today,
and we're happy to be here to sort of kick off one of the first educational
sessions of ACR 2026.
So today, we'll have three speakers in the session, including myself.
The first will be Dr. Jessica Islam, assistant professor at Moffitt
Cancer Center, Dr. Dina Leo O'Malley, associate
professor at the Rutgers Robert Wood Johnson Medical School, and
myself, I'm Jennifer Tsui, professor in the Department of Population and Public
Health Sciences at USC.
So this is an implementation science educational session, so we would be
remiss without setting up what implementation science
is, what we'll be focusing on, and the examples we'll be giving
today. So first, implementation science is the science of
understanding and improving the integration of evidence or
evidence-based practices into the real world.
We do sort of three buckets of science research
understanding. The first is to understand how to distribute
evidence, dissemination science.
The second is how to effectively incorporate new discoveries into
real-world settings, implementation science.
And the third, which many of us study, is how to intervene on the
determinants through implementation strategies that lead to
adoption and practice change.
This is from the Implementation Science at a Glance, which is an NIH
primer that many of you have probably seen before, but it
gives a great overview of the different components of
implementation science, and you can get it freely on the NIH
website. But it covers these aspects of assessing
evidence-based interventions, engaging with stakeholders,
preparing for implementation,
actually implementing, and the theories, models, and frameworks you
utilize to implement strategies, and then evaluating
implementation and implementation outcomes.
So in our session today, we'll be covering all of these aspects.
We'll have Dr. Islam give an example of implementation planning, in
this case of lung cancer screening in HIV care settings.
We'll have Dr. O'Malley focus on participatory engaged approaches to
tailor and select strategies for colorectal cancer
screening. And then I'll cover some approaches and
strategies around sustaining and scaling implementation
strategies for HPV vaccination. All of this is
either in safety net settings or settings
targeting high-risk populations.
So our three main session objectives, the first is to provide an
overview through our examples of commonly used theoretical models and
frameworks in implementation science, to discuss
strategies for designing equity-focused implementation and
dissemination approaches that align with
partnership-engaged
approaches and context and setting-aligned
characteristics and factors. And the last will be to cover
methods for measurement and assessment with the end
goal of planning for sustainability.
So with that, I'm going to ask Dr. Islam to come up here and give our first
talk.
If you step back a little bit. Okay.
Okay. All righty. Thanks, everyone. Good afternoon.
Thank you for joining our session today. As Dr.
Tsui mentioned, for today's talk, I'll be giving an
introductory overview of implementation science methods,
basic definitions, and couple it
with
using an example from my research portfolio focused on lung cancer screening among
people with HIV.
I have no conflicts to disclose.
So for today's agenda, like I mentioned, I'm going to start off by introducing
the lung cancer burden among people with HIV in the United States and why it's
important, and also introduce my R01.
Based on my R01, I'm going to leverage that as an example to describe some
fundamentals of implementation science.
And then at the end, I'll wrap up by sharing future planned implementation
research based on the findings from the R01 that's ongoing.
So to start off with some background, people with HIV in the United States are
aging. With the advent of antiretroviral therapy
in the 1990s, the longevity of people with HIV has increased
over time. With this increase and over time, we've observed an
increase in chronic disease burden.
This graph here is from data from the CDC, and then the
purple and red are those who are aged 45 years and
above. As you can see, over time, the proportion of cases in that
age demographic has increased, and therefore led to an
overall aging or graying of the population.
With the increase in burden of chronic disease, we also need to consider
that people with HIV are more likely to develop multiple cancer types.
We start off here looking at increased risk of AIDS-defining
cancers which occur among people living with HIV.
The CDC defined those at the start of the HIV epidemic as those were
cancers commonly presented at when you presented with
HIV or AIDS at the beginning of the epidemic.And then we
also have a set of other cancers known as non-AIDS defining cancers, among which
lung cancer is one of the leading causes of cancer.
Today, the proportion of cancers that occur among people with HIV are mostly
those non-AIDS defining cancers that are generally
occurring among older populations.
In this graph here, you'll see in red the non-AIDS defining
cancers, and the proportion has increased over time, really
underscoring that the burden of cancer among this aging and growing
population in the US is really these NADCs.
And now with this increase in burden or
shift in the epidemiology, what we observe is that cancer is the leading cause of
morbidity and mortality, specifically lung cancer.
By 2030, this graph shows that the proportion of cancers that occur among this
population will predominantly include lung cancer.
Lung cancer disproportionately impacts people with HIV.
It occurs at higher rates across multiple age groups.
This graph here are standardized incidence ratios, comparing
incidence rates of lung cancer among people with HIV to the general
population, and you'll observe those who are aged between 40 to
69 have an elevated risk. And keep in mind that those who are 40 to
49 are not eligible to receive lung cancer screening in the United States based
on USPSTF guidelines currently. Importantly, people with
HIV, when they are diagnosed with lung cancer, they're more likely to be
diagnosed at those younger age groups and at metastatic stage,
leading to worse cancer specific survival.
So not only does HIV exacerbate your risk of lung
cancer, but there are also social factors or
disadvantage markers that disproportionately impact people living with
HIV that exacerbate this risk of metastatic cancer.
These are data from the National Cancer Database that is currently under
review from my team. What we observed based on this data of about
7,000 people living with HIV and lung cancer is that
75% were diagnosed at metastatic stage.
And
people with HIV had a 15% increased risk of
metastatic lung cancer diagnosis compared to those without HIV.
And socioeconomic factors really exacerbate this disparity.
When you look at ZIP code level, area level educational
attainment, you'll see in blue are those living with HIV, and in black are
those without. The predicted probability of being diagnosed with
metastatic lung cancer is elevated among those with HIV compared to those
without. You see similar patterns when you look at ZIP code level area
income, and when you look at where you receive care, which does
matter among this population. There was an increased
predicted probability of metastatic lung cancer diagnosis
among those with HIV, likely due to referral patterns to receive the best
care possible.
So living with HIV is a unique experience in the cancer
prevention space. There are multilevel factors that we need to take into
consideration, which is a fundamental theory that
guides implementation science research.
There are individual level factors such as income, insurance coverage.
At a hospital setting, there are factors such as trust, healthcare-related
stigma. At the community level, you can think about social services,
safety net programs, and the availability and access to those programs.
And at the structural level, there are factors like Medicaid reimbursement,
national cancer initiatives, and national screening initiatives and policy.
So keeping all of that in mind is what really drove or informed the
development of my latest RO1, funded by the NCI, which
I am framing and I'm thinking about as a pre-implementation
package. All of these aims inform and describe a
complete picture of what is happening, why it's happening, and
from different perspectives involved in the delivery of lung
cancer screening, which is really the foundation for developing implementation
strategies. Aim one is basic descriptive epi.
We're going to characterize patterns of LDCT-based lung cancer screening,
including uptake, outcomes, follow-up, and longitudinal
adherence. We're using big data approaches and electronic health record
data. Aim two is a causal inference aim, where we're going to
estimate the direct and indirect effects of different social determinants of health
using that multilevel framing. And aim three is a
qualitative aim, where we're examining patients' decision-making processes to
get to understand how they got to their lung cancer screening delivery or they
didn't get there. So we're including those with lung
cancer and those who are eligible for lung cancer screening, but not yet
diagnosed. And overarching these three aims, we're going to be including
a community advisory council, which have included in that
group people with HIV, HIV care providers, and
policymakers.
So what is implementation science?
Why am I, as an epidemiologist, interested in
implementation science and leveraging those methods to inform the
translation of key evidence into action?
Well, I want to make sure that the work that I do or the work that
comes out of my lab has actual impact within the community.
I like this figure here. Dr. Sui gave you a definition earlier,
but this figure here really summarizes for me what implementation science
is. It's bridging that gap between what we know
and what we actually practice. It's the study of methods to promote the
adoption and integration of evidence-based
practices.How does implementation science
do that? Well, there are five general buckets that we place
the different theories, models, and frameworks and what they do and how they
serve us when we are doing implementation science work.
Those five buckets include, first, identifying factors.
So understanding those barriers and facilitators that influence the
implementation and clinical practice and integration of new
technology or policies within healthcare systems.
You can use implementation science to help you adapt.
So you know that an intervention works in a specific space and now you want to
adapt and tailor it to your space and make it work to serve your
community. So we have frameworks for that as well.
The next bucket of methods are
to help us develop strategies, specifically to accelerate and improve
the adoption, implementation, and sustainment of different
EBIs. And these last two are actually less leveraged, which I think is a
big gap in the field, but deimplementation of interventions, so those
low-value interventions such as the annual pap.
How do we deimplement those and really provide the
highest quality care possible for the populations we serve?
And then how do we disseminate and scale up?
How do we take something that we know works within a specific HIV
clinic, for example, and scale it up nationally so that the entire network
of people with HIV can receive that high-quality care?
So this is kind of summarizing quickly for us the different stages
or the life course of program implementation.
We start off, this is a graph here of the
life course, if you will, of real-world evidence over time.
We start off thinking about could a program work? Does it work?
Is it effective? Is it efficacious?
Meaning, for example, in the context of LDCT, can it actually
identify lung cancer early? Can it help prevent?
So when we know something is effective, after that stage is usually when
D&I comes into most use.
It's making that program work and ensuring that all
populations are receiving what we know is effective and efficacious over time.
This is a heuristic tool. It's looked like a subway map, which
essentially helps us understand in what
part of the journey of a practice of interest we're in.
This is a common heuristic tool you'll see a lot used in implementation science
to help us understand together as a group, for example, if the
POI is at the stage that it needs to be in order to be considered
implementation. So you start off with the identifying the
practice. You ask yourselves or the group a couple of questions.
Is it efficacious? Is it effective?
And if the answer to that is yes on both fronts, then you are at the stage of
developing a hybrid effectiveness trial or conducting
implementation research like we're doing in my R1.
This is a very simplified, but the
basic concept core of what implementation science is.
This is a heuristic developed by Jeff Curran.
It's published in 2020.
The first is we're starting off with the thing, the intervention,
the EBI. And it sounds simple, but identifying
what the thing is actually is very complicated.
Is it LDCT? Is it a packet of
interventions that we've put together to deliver
LDCT? Is it the educational
intervention that you've developed?
It's amazing how if you put a group of stakeholders in
a room and ask them, "What is the thing that we're implementing?" You'll commonly
get different answers to that question.
So agreeing on the thing is key to ensuring you're doing implementation
science well.
Effectiveness research looks at whether the thing works.
Can LDCT, for example, identify lung cancer
early?
D&I research looks at how best to help the
people and the places that are involved in
implementing do the thing that you've identified. Okay?
And implementation strategies are nothing but the stuff that we do,
whether it's a alert in the EHR, whether it's a patient
navigator. It's essentially the things that we do to help accomplish the
thing, and implementation outcomes are
how much and how well we're doing the thing.
That's really what all it's measuring.
So at the core, this is what implementation science research is.
If you know anything about implementation science, you will have heard of theories,
models, and frameworks. There are many, hundreds, in
fact, of theories, models, and frameworks that are involved in implementation
science. Everybody has their favorite, and everybody has
the best TMF. But what I'm here to tell you is
there is no one perfect theory, model, or framework.
We generally fall back on the one that we were first introduced to, the one we are
most comfortable with, and they all generally measure
similar things.
I don't want you to ever feel like you're boxed into the theory, model,
or framework that you've chosen for your research.
It's essentially a guide to help you and your stakeholders decide
these are the things we could consider, and these are the things we're going to
measure. You don't have to measure all 50 things in the
CFIR which I'm going to talk about in a second, that are
allocated within your framework.
It's just a way to help you think through what you could measure
and what could be considered to deliver your intervention.
So there's three different types of TMFs. I'm not going to go into all of them.
I'm going to give you a couple of examples of commonly used ones, but just know
that there are different types of frameworks based on whether you're looking at
barriers and facilitators, whether you're focusing on evaluation
of the implementation
delivery process. There are different types of frameworks that you can
leverage.Like I mentioned, we're going to talk a little bit about CFIR,
which is the Consolidated Framework for Implementation Science.
It is one of the most commonly used frameworks within IS.
And I'll go over it very briefly here.
There are five major domains. You can start off with the intervention
characteristics, which essentially is the thing.
Is it acceptable? Is it efficacious? Is it effective?
What's the reliability? What's the cost? What's the design?
The outer setting is the world, or the policy,
or the system that you are working within.
So it could be as broad as the US's national
healthcare system or Medicaid policy.
It's essentially the outer critical pieces or the environment which you're
working within.
The inner setting is usually the hospital, the clinic, the school, wherever
you're implementing your intervention.
Then there's the characteristics of the people involved, so the different
stakeholders, and then the process of implementation.
So that's assessing context. That's that barriers and facilitators um
exercise. That's adaption, reflecting, depending on where you are in the
implementation or what's your objective. Is it adaptation?
Is it identifying barriers, et cetera.
So I'm going to give you just a quick example of a very
few examples of measures that we're doing in our
R01 to give you a flavor of what these things mean.
So when we talk about the outer setting, what it means, like I said, is
external forces, social determinants of health, policy, and
community context.
Aim two of the R01 is understanding those multilevel
barriers, which includes exposome data such as
neighborhood-level factors, healthcare access, et cetera.
The inner setting, which we can talk about in terms of the health
system factors, so culture, resources, electronic health
records access. That's really aim one and two.
Aim one and two go over... Two is the multilevel SDOH.
Aim one are factors like uptake, longitudinal adherence, that really gets at
the inner setting. What are the patterns of care we're observing within a
healthcare system?
Individuals involved with, like I said, would be the different stakeholders
involved, so understanding the knowledge, attitudes, and different types of
self-efficacy from different perspectives.
So that's really in aim three, where we're understanding people living with HIV's
decision-making process, barriers to access of lung cancer screening, et
cetera.
Innovation characteristics would be understanding or characteristics of
LDCT, which is less of a focus since we know it is effective among people with
HIV.
And process, which is how implementation is inactive and by whom,
is really all aims. And also the inclusion of the CAB, which will help us
walk through a process of implementation mapping, integration of all
information, and thinking about the testing and delivery of the
intervention in our next project.
So we talked a little bit about exposure, so determinants through that
CFIR framework. Now we're going to talk about outcomes.
So think about the end of the intervention.
What is it that we need to measure to ensure or to
demonstrate that our intervention works well
within the context or the system that we're working in?
This is
a fundamental framework developed by Enola Proctor in 2011,
which outlines...
She gave us the first set of definitions of what are implementation
outcomes, how do we define them, and how do we measure them, and what's important.
So these are things like feasibility, fidelity.
Fidelity just means how well did you implement the
intervention the way it was meant to be implemented.
Penetration, acceptability, cost, et cetera.
So this, I'm just going to use my R01 to give you an example of what you
could measure to measure implementation outcomes.
Acceptability would come from aim three, thinking about satisfaction with lung
cancer screening delivery.
Aim one, we're going to assess appropriateness, so we're going to think about
age at lung cancer diagnosis among people with HIV.
So do the guidelines actually fit for this population that we're focusing on?
And penetration and reach would be, for example, the proportion of eligible people
living with HIV who are screened, which is one of our main outcomes in aim one.
So this is stepping into the future.
I just wanted to give you a
quick overview of what this could look like.
So we are identifying the different determinants in the
R01.
As a CAB or as a community with my CAB, we're going to
conduct an implementation mapping process.
I don't go into what implementation mapping is.
It has a very specific set of methodologies.
But if you're interested in learning more, I would highly suggest you look at
Dr. Maria Fernandez's work. She's a pioneer in this field.
Think through match strategies or strategies that we, as
a group,
agree on, and then really develop and deliver that hybrid type two or three
trial.
So a couple of examples. Again, these are hypothetical.
This is not the outcome of my R01, just potential opportunities or
things that we could potentially focus on.
So for example, if we identify a barrier being
the provider knowledge gap about lung cancer screening
eligibility, a strategy might be conducting educational
outreach or helping develop shared decision-making tools that are integrated into
electronic health record. If we identify a barrier could be
patient distrust or competing health priorities, a strategy might
be developing community health worker navigation processes
that are integrated within HIV clinics.
If we identify one of the main factors is a social
determinant of health, such as transportation, which leads to
no-show for that diagnostic LDCT, we might develop
patient reminder calls as an intervention or co-locate
LDCT at or near the HIV clinic. And you'll notice in boxes
here, the ERIC, what I'm referring to as ERIC strategies.
If you want to learn more, this is a compilation of implementation
strategies developed by Dr.
Byron Powell and colleagues, which is essentially a
bank of strategies that we know works in
implementation science.And then we'll move
on. I wanted to give quick definitions about what a hybrid effectiveness trial is.
So this are three different types of trials, and they have different focuses.
Hybrid type one is when you focus on the
effectiveness of the intervention rather than the
implementation outcomes. Hybrid two is when you equally balance the
measurement of those two. And hybrid three is when you really are focusing on
those implementation outcomes rather than effectiveness.
And I have examples here of what those could look like.
Really quickly, at the core of
implementation science is equity.
Equity should be integrated into intervention development at all stages.
These are a couple of principles that have been developed by experts such as
Prajakta De Sul and Anna Bauman at Wash U in St. Louis.
I encourage you to read their papers that demonstrate or summarize
for us what are different implementation science principles that
hold equity at its core.
So to summarize, key takeaways,
knowing that the EBI is effective is not enough.
We know lung cancer screening prevents lung cancer deaths, but only if
people with HIV or the target population can actually access it.
Implementation science will help us bridge that gap.
Our R01 that we've presented here is in pre-implementation science
package, and it maps directly onto different IS constructs to help us
develop that intervention to be tested in the future.
It gives us a vocabulary and a roadmap to identify the different
stages of intervention development, and equity must be built in
from the start.
These are my acknowledgments.
And if you have any follow-up questions, feel free to email me or follow me on Blue
Sky.
Thank you so much.
We're going to take questions at the end.
Good afternoon. I'm going to just get adjusted to the volume for a second.
So I'm going to talk today about using participatory engaged approaches to
select implementation strategies for safety net contexts.
I'm going to focus on my NCI
K99R00,
that focused on using resources strategically to prioritize
colorectal cancer screening for patients with diabetes in federally qualified
health centers.
So, that helpful vocabulary that Dr.
Islam has introduced us to. Again,
we are interested in looking at the scientific study of
methods to promote the systematic uptake of
research into practice.
So implementation science is inherently a social change
process in a care delivery setting.
We know that historically, top-down approaches do not work to
getting evidence translated into practice.
So for this study, what we focused on in terms of the thing was
colorectal cancer screening, which is actually a complex thing
because there's multiple evidence-based screening strategies that can be
used. They are all different in terms of the interval for
screening, and so they all require different levels of resources from
the patients, providers, and systems that deliver them.
And then the implementation research looks at how can we best help people and
places do the thing. So the people in this case are patients,
primary care providers, the support staff who support their work,
and in the FQHC clinical context, which is a primary care safety net
setting.
And then the stuff that we do to help people do the thing
are...
The story that I'm going to take you through today is how we used an implementation
planning process to do the implementation mapping
strategy pioneered by...
Sorry, I forgot that.
To do the thing. So before we go. So colorectal cancer screening.
So the why. So early detection for colorectal cancer screening is
key. Colorectal cancer is preventable through the mechanism of polyp
detection and highly treatable when it's caught early.
So the options are, as I mentioned, complicated.
So there's this stool-based testing, which are FIT and FOBT tests or
Cologuard tests,
versus direct visualization. That's the what we want people to
do. And the average risk
population are patients who are 45 to 75 years old,
the who that we want screened. And during the process of this
study, which is in its last year,
the screening age changed from 50
to 45. So it's important in implementation science to recognize that all of
the systems that we work with, even the thing, is dynamic and can change.
So being flexible is important.
So the overarching research question for this study was, can we
target implementation strategies for patients with diabetes in federally
qualified health centers to increase the uptake of preventative colorectal
cancer screening tests? And when I was first developing this, I was
moving, because this was a career award, from the area of cancer survivorship into
cancer prevention. So colorectal cancer screening was a new
thing for me. And when I was developing this, I met with a
gastroenterologist and he said, "You know, diabetes patients should
all receive colonoscopies, especially if
FQHCs are inconsistently implementing evidence-based
practices." And the power of community-based participatory
research is that if you talk to people who work in FQHCs, they'll tell you that
that is an infeasible strategy, out of the gate.
So while it might sound like the best evidence, it's not a thing that's going to
work in these contexts.
SoFirst, in the framing of the research question was
developing a case for prioritizing patients with
diabetes for colorectal cancer screening in FQHCs.
Why would we want to do that? There is no guideline that says that we should
prioritize patients with diabetes for colorectal cancer screening.
But what we do know about this context is there is a long implementation lag.
So the first landmark study that the evidence base
was founded upon was in 1996.
In 12 years, 50% of the US population was receiving
colorectal cancer screening nationally.
In 2020, we reached 72%
nationally. Twenty-eight years later, we still have
not met the 50% threshold for colorectal cancer screening in the
FQHC space. That's despite this being the most widely
studied screening process in the NHI
portfolio. So it's not for lack of trying,
not at the research level and not at the practice level either.
So why would we focus on patients with diabetes?
Well, patients with diabetes are 27% more likely to have a
colorectal cancer diagnosis in their lifetime.
And upon diagnosis, patients with diabetes experience more complications and
morbidity and greater mortality.
And we know that colorectal cancer screening, when implemented in an
evidence-based manner, can prevent colorectal
cancer from happening, or it can be detected early
where it's much more easily treatable.
So who in the population is benefiting from this
evidence? I would argue that we don't have an evidence problem in
colorectal cancer
early detection. We have an implementation problem, and that's largely
based
on resources. So
we know that socioeconomic factors, those drivers, are what
is causing these disparities.
And when we think about the context of FQHCs,
we also need to think about the patient population and in this
context, because patients with diabetes in
FQHCs do not have the same
equivalent burden of diabetes as a general population.
Thirty to 32% of FQHC patients have poor
glucose control.
And patients with diabetes are about two times more likely
to have poor control than the general population.
So in a busy primary care clinic, what that means
is that a provider needs to decide whether or not to prioritize a patient's glucose
control or their general preventive screening.
So I'm going to focus today on the last two aims of my study to take
us through the story of how we got to the implementation strategies through this
participatory engaged process.
And then once we developed those strategies and identified them,
we developed a toolkit, and then we delivered a tailored,
facilitated
practice change approach in three practices.
I'm going to just tell you the story of two for today,
and you'll have to wait for the paper for the outcomes
because they'll be coming to me hopefully next month.
But there's lots to talk about in getting there.
So during the K99, I did an implementation science
scholars program that was out of Wash U.
And at the time, I think right before then, Ross Bronson, who
was one of the MPIs who led that, had published this "Implementation Science in
Health Equity." How can we do better in implementation science?
And what
my research focused on mainly was
designing and tailoring the implementation strategies.
But the highlighted pieces here are the things that I would say that
my study attended to prior to this being brought to the
fore. This was being done, I think, before this, but I think it
highlights how can we do better.
So implementation mapping.
There are five steps in the implementation
mapping process that I'm going to take us through.
So the first is the needs assessment and identification of potential
adopters. So who needs this? What do we need them
to do? And why does it matter?
So the what.
What are the colorectal cancer screenings by test type in these
settings? Which populations are being missed?
What are the consequences for that group?
The why. Why is it being missed? And this is at every
level, and then the interactions between those levels.
So who are the potential adopters?
And who do we need to do what?
Then the second piece of this, which was the focus of...
So aim one of this K99 focused on this
first step. Then we looked at
statement of the adoption and change objectives.
So the tasks required to adopt, implement, and maintain a program.
Next, we choose theoretical models and select implementation strategies, the how.
This study was guided by the EPIS framework, which is a
process framework that really looks at the
pieces of the how and the why of doing the different
strategies. So it's the
dynamic of change process model. But we also focus
heavily on the thing which is not emphasized in this model.
To Dr. Islam's point, we borrow from other models when it fits
the question.
And then using taxonomies of theories to address individual and
organizational level strategies.
The fourth step is producing implementation protocols and materials and
evaluate implementation outcomes.
And you can do this implementation mapping process a number of
ways. The way that we did it for this study was using an implementation planning
group, which included diverse implementation actors from a
variety of FQHCs in New Jersey.
We recruited 18 differentClinicians,
members of the Department of Health who ran
cancer screening and
minority health initiatives. We included the NJ SEED
program, which is our safety net screening program
liaison and we had about 10 members from
FQHCs that included social workers, executive
directors,
patient navigators, physicians, advanced practice nurses.
So at the first meeting, what we did was develop a charter.
So what we wanted this team to do was determine the
targets for optimization of colorectal cancer screening for patients with
diabetes.
So
our first meeting, we really wanted to get people talking, so we asked people,
"What do you think is getting in the way?"
And then based on that conversation, we analyzed all of the
things that people came
up with in the meeting and fed that back to them in the second meeting.
And in that second meeting, we were able to rank the strategies in order of
greatest importance and feasibility to identify the top three
that they really wanted to dig into.
And then we explored key issues surrounding the implementation to develop a
plan and supports to make that plan
implementable.
We inventoried the proposed challenges from the multiple levels and the
contextual factors
and identified key resources to overcome barriers and
supports.
I'm going to show you some of the materials that we used, more of a
how-to, but the brainstorming question was: What should we be
considering when planning to implement colorectal cancer screening to improve
rates for patients with diabetes?
They came up with about 36 different things, so these are the top five.
And there were two buckets. One was
patient education and communication, and the other one was clinical flow.
And so we fed these back to them in very much the language that they
used when they said them.
The second
piece was looking at the clinical workflow process, so adding
colorectal cancer screening as a part of routine diabetes care and informing
patients, pop-up reminders in the EHR, diabetes
educators. All of these map back to the ERIC Taxonomy of
Implementation Strategies in different buckets.
But we did not organize them in terms of those buckets just yet.
We refined that list further in the second meeting and
then used the ERIC Taxonomy of Implementation Strategies to
adapt them to what that would look like for this
particular change initiative. So instead of build a
coalition, period, it was build a coalition, recruit, and cultivate
relationships with partners and FQHCs to
support the implementation effort to improve colorectal cancer screening.
So,
really explaining what that implementation strategy meant for the different
members of the group.
Then after we
selected top strategies, we went through as a
group, at what point of the implementation
process would we need to be thinking about this strategy?
Is this a pre-implementation or adoption consideration?
Is this an implementation consideration or something for maintenance?
So then we picked apart the strategy together as a group.
Who is involved? What do we need them to do?
What are the barriers and facilitators to them doing it?
So the top four strategies that were
selected by the group were identify and prepare champions, develop
and distribute educational materials for colorectal cancer screening for
patients with diabetes. There was a lot of
caveats to these. So that second one was they needed to be
low literacy. They needed to include
how to do the different test type that they were prioritizing
as their thing.
And the other piece was that they needed to have control over
how they were distributing them.
Then develop and organize quality monitoring systems.
In federally qualified health centers, UDS metrics, the Uniform Data System
metrics, are required by HRSA as a function of their funding.
However, a precision
prevention approach is not something
that these systems have to do. So they
wanted some guidance on what are the metrics that matter here.
And then organize clinical implementation meetings to support the
effort.
So the implementation planning group came up with these strategies, and then
we conducted key implementation interview actors, which is just
a lot of jargony words for these are people who we would want to do these change
things. We wanted to talk to the people whose roles would be affected from
that mapping strategy of who we needed to do what.
And from those interviews, we really dug in on, does your system have the capacity
to be able to look at whether or not patients with diabetes are
being screened at a better rate or not? Would that be hard for you?
What kind of support would you need?
The culmination of this work was the
development of an implementation toolkit, which would take me 20 minutes to go
through in and of itself.
And then the next phase was to determine the preliminary effectiveness of
the implementation strategies for targeting colorectal cancer screening.
And our primary outcomes were clinic-level
screening uptake by test type and with an exploratory
aim of colorectal cancer screening uptake by
glycemic control.
And then the key implementation outcomes were,
is this implementation or implementation strategies, are they
feasible? And are they acceptable by both the patients
and the
actors whose roles or functions changed as a result of
them?So, this is just an example from the
toolkit. We had multiple different educational pieces
as a part of this. We wanted the practices to have all of the
materials for the entire screening trajectory.
So, a reminder that they needed screening, a result letter,
a sample letter,
infographics that could be printed about the elevated
risk for colorectal cancer among patients with diabetes, and then
general resources like the community guide one-pager.
These were some of the metrics
that we suggested people look
at. So the number of patients overall who are eligible for colorectal cancer
screening, the number of patients with diabetes who are eligible,
the type of tests
that people are being recommended to complete, which was generally
stool-based tests.
Most of the sites picked Cologuard because it's a three-year screening
interval instead of a one-year screening interval with the
rationale that if these could be reimbursed, it actually would
be a lower lift from a resource perspective for
the sites to keep their patient population up to
date.
So, I'm going to tell you a little bit about two of the practices,
clinic A and clinic B. They are both in the same FQHC system, which is
a disadvantage. This was a feasibility pilot also, so what we
learned was that what they report to the UDS measures are actually
aggregated by clinic. So, what that means is that the two different
sites that we were working with had different colorectal
cancer screening rates at baseline.
But we didn't ask them for that data initially because we didn't know that.
But we did get specific data about screening rates for patients with diabetes.
Now, I would say that clinic A is probably the better performer overall for
colorectal cancer screening. Their patients with diabetes were screened at a rate
of 77%, which was very high.
The breakdown of non-screened for patients with diabetes were well-controlled
patients
who were unscreened, were 10% of the unscreened.
Controlled were 54%, and not controlled were
36%.
So how did clinic A...
What did they do with the toolkit? Right?
So clinic A had the most motivated champion.
She was basically in our learning collaborative telling the
other people what they should do. She had met with the Cologuard
rep, gotten a discounted rate for the site,
knew all about their navigation program.
So she was like an
information powerhouse in this learning collaborative.
She
and two other people in her site wanted to continue to advance their Cologuard
first strategy. So during the initial intervention
phase, they communicated the importance of colorectal cancer for patients with
diabetes to the other staff in their site.
And then during morning huddles, they would remind each other about
who's coming in that day, who had a diabetes diagnosis, who was not up to
date.
They made use of postcards in Spanish and English and did a mail
campaign to increase the colorectal cancer screening uptake
for patients with diabetes who were unscreened.
And we developed
postcards, but each of the sites did something different with them.
Performance site B
was the other site that had a 28% screening rate overall.
But we don't know what the difference is.
We do know that the difference from them thinking about
the differences of their diabetes uptake,
that the one site that did better overall had more of
a Medicaid-insured population, where clinic B had more
of an uninsured population. So the Cologuard strategy that clinic
A had developed wouldn't really work for clinic B for
their uninsured population. However, they were
emboldened by clinic site A's strategy.
They met with the rep, and they got a discounted rate for
their uninsured population as well.
So the screening rate for patients with diabetes was 60%.
The breakdown by non-screened were that well-controlled
patients
represented 10% of the non-screened population, controlled were
60%, and not controlled were 30%. So in both
cases, we saw that controlled patients, not well-controlled,
were actually the largest population of patients with diabetes who were
unscreened.
And in this site,
what they did was adapt the postcard
with the QR code from the Cologuard site,
because the Cologuard site has instructions on how
to do the
test at
home. It's a video that you can access on your phone in
eight different languages. So they built an awareness campaign by
having postcards in the clinic waiting room,
and then they focused on both overall colorectal cancer screening and
with a sub-focus on patients with diabetes using
the Fit First strategy. The two diabetes posters were posted in highly
visible areas, and the medical students were trained on the specifics of the
test and the educational counseling of the patients.
So,
we're going to have to stay tuned for the follow-up data, but the core principle is
that building solutions with the community who
needs to both buy in and understand
and adapt different parts of the change process is key.
So in the implementation planning process, diversity in roles,
experiences, and the value of contextual
wisdomis unparalleled. The
story of the person from clinic A and their influence
in the group,
we couldn't have planned that better and the shared
decision-making. The idea that
when you're coming from a different context looking at this problem
when I started conceptualizing this research question, the idea that everyone
with diabetes should get test B was the
mandate, but that's not going to work in the real world.
And the community-based participatory advantage is that you come up with solutions
that contextually fit. There's a bi-directional learning.
So we're learning as much from the experts who are in real practice
settings as we can provide them with knowledge.
And the hope is that we make lasting practice
change,
that everybody feels a part of ownership of.
So
we're going to take questions at the end, and thank you for your attention.
Okay. I understand. This
last talk will be the last thing that stands between you and whatever's happening
on Friday night here in San Diego, so I'll try to wrap
us up. I think the beauty of this panel and why I am
constantly in awe of hearing about the research of Dr. Islam and Dr.
O'Malley is that there is so much analogous
work going on in implementation science across cancer sites
and across regions in the US, but a lot of the, what we call
jargony implementation science terminology has
started to settle a bit, and I think the field has really moved quite a
bit towards
partnerships and understanding impact and outcomes, and that's a
nice place to be,
compared to where I think many of us have started in our career in the space of
implementation science. So I'm going to wrap us up
to talk about what happens after uptake.
What happens when something works, right?
What happens after we've implemented, we've measured outcomes,
and we start to talk about sustainment, sustainability, and scaling.
So we've mentioned a couple of these evidence-based
practices in cancer control already throughout the session today,
but I think a lot of our reasoning for the
need for implementation science comes from this piece
that was published by Dr. Chambers and Keelan Netta and
colleagues at NCI to show this lag between when a
seminal paper comes out around the effectiveness of a cancer
control intervention or tool and when it is actually
taken up by the population. The piece that I'll focus on
today is on HPV vaccination, and we are just coming
on to the 20th anniversary, the 20th birthday of the
HPV vaccination, the vaccine. And we'll talk a little bit
about what uptake has been like over the
last 20 years,
and why we still need implementation science to help us get to optimal levels
of uptake.
So first, the thing, the vaccine, is highly
effective. It protects against high-risk HPV types that lead
to multiple cancer sites or associated with multiple cancer sites.
And we've seen that in countries and regions of the world where
there has been high population-level uptake of the vaccine,
they are starting to see zero cases of invasive cervical
cancer.
So what about here in the US?
We know that we've had changing guidelines over the last 20 years.
We've started to shift our focus from age 11 and 12 down to
age nine.
We have
followed and looked at movement towards the one-dose
recommendation. We have recently moved to that in our advisory
committee on immunization practices, though I don't know if that's a real thing
right now or not, but we have moved to one dose, although
anticlimactically here in the US.
And I will say also importantly, we have had to struggle and
deal with multiple levels, multi-level challenges to
implementation around vaccine hesitancy, around the
politicization of vaccines, and the increasing
misinformation that is out there on social media and other
venues. And so that's why improving HPV
vaccination is critical for cancer equity but also requires
implementation strategies.
So in Los Angeles, where this work that I'll present
today is based, we are still hovering around 55% to
49% uptake for the first dose.
While nationally, we have reached somewhere around 70%,
at local levels, we see much wider disparities in
HPV vaccination uptake. A few years ago, we
did a study and published this piece on the relationship
between medical mistrust and parental HPV vaccine hesitancy,
and have continued to think about and develop
materials to target information messaging needs for
multiethnic communities in large, diverse regions of the US.
But what is the issue around HPV vaccinations?
So first, it's that we have multiple evidence-based
strategies that have been studied and that have been shown to be
effective in improving uptake in clinic settings.
Anything from the announcement approach for providers, starting at
age nine, using standard orders,
tailoring and targeting clinic teams, et cetera.
However, how do we know which strategies we should use, how best to
align them in the clinics we're targeting and the populations that need them being
served by those clinics?And
additionally, why focus on safety net settings? I think Dr. Islam and Dr.
O'Malley both mentioned why it's critical to go to the
settings where burden is high, where uptake is lagged,
and where we need to study how we can accelerate
uptake of these effective cancer control tools.
So adolescent HPV vaccination remains low in medically
underserved communities, particularly in FQHC
settings. We focused very little on our interventions
or on our strategies at the clinic staff level.
So there's a lot of provider physician recommendation interventions,
a lot of parents and individual-level focused
interventions, but much less on that clinic staff and that clinic
team delivery step. And lastly, we haven't really thought
as much in recent years about what it means to co-design for
sustainability. We know FQHCs have
fewer resources, are understaffed, have had significant
impact with the COVID-19 pandemic, and
so restarting
co-designing interventions in the current context is
critically important to figuring out how we can sustain strategies so we're
not doing one study after another over a 20-year period to
try to improve uptake.
So this study is an NCI-funded R37.
It started as a four-year R01, where we really focused
on implementing evidence-based strategies in
three clinics in a large FQHC setting.
And then in the current merit phase, the two-year phase, we have this opportunity
to understand and assess sustainability and scale up.
It's a study that started at USC with
collaborators at Rutgers. It has since now expanded to collaborators at
UC San Diego and the University of Washington.
So this is the overall implementation phase of
the R01 piece of the study. So we went in and
partnered with Ultimed Healthcare Corporation, which is one of
the largest FQHCs in the Southern California region.
They have over 50 clinic sites. We conducted a baseline
assessment using the practice change model and CFIR, many
of the frameworks that my co-panelists have talked about already.
We implemented a 12-month implementation phase,
and then we assessed post-implementation outcomes.
The three strategies that we implemented were audit and feedback with clinic
teams and clinic leadership, provider communication training
using an evidence-based tool developed by colleagues at the University of North
Carolina called the Announcement Approach, and then we
co-designed and co-developed clinic staff trainings and workflow
assessment with our collaborators at the American Cancer
Society.
What we found in that main implementation phase, and what
we observed at the end of the evaluation, was
that the three clinic sites where we implemented these strategies had a
significantly higher increase in rates of HPV vaccine
initiation at the end of 12 months compared to comparison
sites.
Much of this was driven by the increase in ages nine to
10 uptake rates. So a lot of our strategies
focused on those shifting guidelines and the shifting context of starting at
younger ages, and we saw that translate in our outcomes at the
end.
So my talk today is not about what we observed in that
implementation, what we evaluated.
We presented that at the Academy Health DNI conference last
December. But what we're talking about today is really about
sustainability and where we're at.
So what happens after we figure out something works, the
clinics love it, they want to keep going.
What do we need to do to keep it sustained, right?
So one, we know that sustainability of
strategies in safety net settings is challenging because there are resource
constraints.
The clinic settings that we worked with, Ultimed, is a
huge system compared to other smaller FQHCs.
They have a director of vaccines. They have a director of nursing research.
So there are the resources to have
motivation for sustainability. But even then, the long-term
resources are limited, right? We also know that
there are factors at the inner and outer context that
impact sustainability, and we know that in the field of implementation
science,
something that has been understudy to date is measurement
around implementation approaches and implementation outcomes when it
comes to sustainment and sustainability.
So where are we now with sustainability in our assessment of, is this
feasible to sustain, and can it be sustainable?
So we went back to the clinics 18 months after our implementation
period to evaluate some of these determinants of
sustainability. We used a rapid assessment
approach,
which was developed by Dr. Larry Palinkas, one of our collaborators on
this study.
It's a mixed methods evaluation approach where we use surveys and
interviews as well as electronic health records to
understand what's going on in the clinic.
We also use the clinical sustainability assessment tool to
measure specific
factors related to sustainability of our three evidence-based
strategies.
From our surveys, what we found was that at the clinic level and the clinic team
level, there was a sustained use of increasing
HPV vaccination discussion at age nine.
So that piece that we found from the main study had sustained.
In fact, it had gone up a little bit to 88% of providers and clinic
staff saying that they still start discussion at age nine.
We also found that the confidence that we observed among clinic staff
saying that they were able to or felt that they were equipped to address parental
hesitancy had also sustained. That
confidence69% of clinic staff reported
that they felt confident continuing to address parental hesitancy, and
this is an increase from where we were at the 12-month survey.
In terms of the assessment tool, the CSAT tool, we found
that among staff, and this is on a scale of one to seven, the
majority of staff felt that our evidence-based strategies that we implemented and
co-designed with them were easy to use, could be integrated into
their workflow, their practice, their EMR, could be designed to
be used consistently across their clinic sites, and
had clinically meaningful impact on their patient
population. We found similar outcomes with our providers for
most of the measures. However, providers had a slightly lower
perception on whether these tools around communication
and workflow improvement had a clinically meaningful
impact on patients.
We also conducted qualitative interviews.
So from the qualitative interviews, we also found continued
endorsement of effectiveness and
sustainment of HPV vaccination, particularly at age
nine. Adoption of those earlier age group recommendations.
We found implementation was already being discussed and
implemented in the broader FQHC
system, including putting our education tools on the SharePoint
and integrated into their nursing education curriculum.
And then lastly, this support and motivation for
sustainability was there. But what we found was that there still
continued to be a lot of turnover for both physician and
staff in FQHCs. And this is something we hadn't talked about in some of the
prior
presentations in this panel, but something that we have to
continuously acknowledge in these safety net settings is that you
may train the clinic staff once, and you come back 24 months
later and 50% of the staff have already turned over.
So when we talk about sustainability and sustainment, that dynamic change,
even in the inner context setting, is very
real and very ongoing.
So a peek at sustainment outcomes.
What we found 18 months after leaving the 12-month
implementation period was that the sustainment of
HPV vaccination for ages nine to 10 year olds had
roughly stayed around the same. So we had kept that
level from when we last intervened with the clinics.
However, we saw this dip in 11 to 12 year olds, and right now we're
currently trying to assess if that is because they've replaced
the 11 to 12-year-old vaccinations with the nine to 10 year olds, or if there's
in fact sort of a decrease in vaccine uptake there.
So the last piece that I'll focus on today is on scaling out.
So in addition to that first red box up there that I just covered on
sustainability, we also wanted to know what would it
take to go from this large FQHC health
system to other types of FQHCs. Those of you who work
in this space, if you've seen one FQHC system, you've seen one
FQHC system, right? Sometimes you see one clinic in an
FQHC, and you've only seen one clinic.
They vary quite a bit within systems, but
also across FQHC organizations.
So the thing about scale-out, right? What is scale-out or what is scaling?
What is scaling up? Dr. Greg Aarons published about this in
2017, that scaling up is really expanding the use of
evidence-based strategies to new populations, to different
settings, different communities.
Without systematic assessment of scaling, we really don't know
what
factors are needed to address equity and whether we can fully
benefit populations overall in terms of trying to
accelerate and implement cancer control tools
across communities. And so in our scale-out component, our focus
was really to identify factors and strategies that
would be important to think about implementing these
same three strategies, audit and feedback, provider
communication training, clinic staff education, and workflow
assessments,
into other FQHCs serving different communities.
So we started with AltaMed. It's quite a big
FQHC system. They have 60 sites across two counties in Southern
California. They primarily serve Hispanic, some African
American, and Asian patients. Most of their staff
are bilingual and speak English and Spanish.
And when we scale out, we partnered with these two other FQHC
settings. The first is Chinatown Service Center, much smaller
FQHC system, seven sites, primarily
serving Chinese and other Asian-American communities
in Central and East LA.
Some of their staff are bilingual, and many of them are bilingual in a
different language, and so the resources and the trainings we used had to be
adapted. The second FQHC system we scaled out
to was Riverside San Bernardino Indian Health Incorporated.
So this is a nine-site community
health clinic system serving American Indian and Alaska
Native patients. And so again, different
populations. This is a much more rural area.
The clinics are spread out across the different tribal
regions in the Riverside and San Bernardino counties.
And so we found a lot of outer setting context as well
as inner setting factors that we had to think about if we really wanted
to be able to support and enable
scale-out of our strategies to other
FQHCs.These are just some pictures of
the partners that we've worked with in these two sites.
I won't go into too much of the detail.
We're still collecting and analyzing these data.
But I will say that one of the key ingredients that were
critical to all three was having bidirectional
conversations, ongoing co-design, and
co-development of the strategies, and to really be
aligned with their target populations and their
current clinic capacity. So
some of the findings that
emerged, that we really realized we needed to be sensitive and
aware of, were differing cultural norms, not just their
patient
population, but even the clinic setting and the clinic team.
So, the workflow and the inner setting,
as well as the community barriers and cultural norms.
Other aspects that were important were around the baseline knowledge and
awareness of providers and clinic staff.
In one clinic,
MAs had been there for much longer, were aware of HPV
vaccination guidelines. In another clinic, they were much
less
aware or had not been trained in recent years about HPV
vaccination.
So, another piece to be cognizant about is just the
logistics and the infrastructure that is different
across clinics. So when we were at AltaMed, we did our
clinic staff
trainings in person at each clinic
separately. That was what they wanted.
They wanted each clinic site to have their own face-to-face training
with the clinic staff. When we were at Chinatown Service Center, they had
monthly trainings and meetings with all of their clinic staff, where
everyone called in virtually, across the different sites.
And so that was the way we needed to deliver the training.
And then at Riverside San Bernardino, they came
together in multiple sites.
They had specific
clinic locations where some of the clinics would congregate
together and some remained at their own sites.
So these types of hybrid opportunities for
training are just
factors that you have to keep in mind in order to deliver
anything. And I think,
while face-to-face often seems more
resource-intensive, it's become
less and less the priority for many of these clinics, both
for logistical reasons and for clinic staff scheduling
reasons.
So to end, I think, just some key takeaway points about
sustainability and scaling and DNI research for cancer control.
The first is the critical need to co-design from the start.
Without co-designing and having continuous bidirectional
communication with your target setting and your target communities,
that ability to think about and align with their capacity
will be really difficult.
The second is engagement to inform
adaptation. These are dynamic cancer
control tools and also dynamic contexts we're working in.
Guidelines change, age guidelines change.
The best evidence out there will change.
And so being able to adapt over time, not just
the strategies to enable cancer control tools, but
also being able to change with the context that you're working
in.
The measurement piece, I think, of this field is still
growing, and so those of you in the audience who are interested in
this
part of cancer control and implementation science, I really
urge you to participate and contribute and maybe
challenge the frameworks and the measures that are out there.
I think if there's one singular message that
we've given today, it's that there's lots of
frameworks, there's lots of terminology, but at the end of
the day, just be clear on the thing that you're doing,
the people you're trying to work with, and
try to understand how you can best enable them to do the thing.
And with that, I think I will end. I want to thank my team.
It takes a village to get to sustainability,
and it takes a village to do implementation science.
So really think about the resources that you need to get all of this
done. With that, I think we'll open up for questions.
Thank you.
We do have about
15 to 20 minutes for questions, so feel free
to come up to the mic. I know you've been staring at us in the
dark. We're real people up here, but go to the mic.
I'm going to check to see if there's anyone on virtually who's asking questions,
too.
Is the mic in the middle on? It is?
Hello, hello. Now it's on.
Thank you all. That was a really great presentation.
I guess my question is, as a non-expert and someone new to the field,
would you mind each saying something
that...
You described these frameworks and implementation.
Can you talk about something that you might have wished that you would've known at
the beginning,
that would've been helpful for where you are today?
So something you might have done differently or some information you might have
wanted to know upfront.
Either of you can go first.
Well,
it's
interesting in implementation study because so many
things change from the time that you write a grant and have
an idea, to the time when the rubber meets the road.
So what I would have wanted to know was how much time and
energy it was going to take to make the implementation
strategies into a produced
toolkit.
Mm-hmm.
This was an R00 study, so it's not funded at the same level as, say, an
R01.
Mm-hmm.
Depending upon what your group decides they want to
do,
what you need to develop could be pretty sophisticated.
So doing that within your budgetary constraints
and timeline can be a real challenge.
I think I'll speak to sustainability.
And when we think about the intervention or
the program we're trying to implement, we're usually
doing it with a grant, like an R01, within a setting that
has a limited capacity or limited resources.
And I think the key to ensuring that the program or the work that
you're doing will be successful is ensuring that the
system you're working with or the clinics you're working with have
the opportunity to sustain what you're doing
after the grant is over and after the project is done.
I'm not at that stage yet, but I think at the core of
thinking about implementation science is thinking
about equity and sustainment, and actually
bringing impact to the communities that we work with.
And I think it's missed or left out of the conversation
sometimes.
I think the first question that we should be asking ourselves before we implement
is, how do we sustain after this project, which hasn't
even started, but after it's over, how do we ensure that this work will
actually matter?
So that's
one thing that I think people should think about more before
implementing at all.
I'm going to give maybe a practical reflection, and
that is how long it might take these clinics that we partner with
to give us data.
Yeah.
It takes so long for them to give us data, and without that, you
sort of can't monitor if it's working or if it's sustaining or
any of that.
Yeah.
And I would say if I had to do it all over again from six,
seven years ago from when this first started,
it would be to focus on getting that data first.
Yeah.
The other pieces of implementing and recruitment, those we know, and
we can work effectively to get those done, but the data
are still
out of our control. Right?
Yeah.
This is An Chung from Albert Einstein College of Medicine.
Thank you all for giving
so much great depth about implementation science.
So I think I want to ask a follow-up question.
All of you sharing is, for me also as very new, could
be even naive about implementation sciences.
How can we motivate, or
maybe what are the motivations,
maybe incentives, can we get
these
clinicians and also the safety network hospitals or
maybe general clinics to get involved
with this implementation research?
Because one thing I observe in our health system,
somehow very integrated health system and multi-field.
We, even ourself, have an issue involving our
collaborating
clinicians or whatever, to do something, even if we
actually offer this service for free.
So I think I would appreciate your opinions.
I think especially Dr.
Tsui, if I pronounce your family name correct.
You're involved so many clinics, so I want to really know what's
happening behind the scene.
So just to repeat the question,
you
want
us to discuss a little bit about working with clinics and
motivation-
And buy-in
... and buy-in from the different settings, providers.
Yes.
Okay. Yeah. Do either of you want to go first?
Sure. So I think one thing that we've talked about
today, I discussed how equity is a core principle of
implementation science. Dr. O'Malley talked about participatory
methods. And I think the
key to or the
rationale behind integrating participatory methods into your
implementation science package development is
ensuring that the setting or the clinic you're working
with cares about what you care about.
Or really, it's vice versa.
As researchers, I think one of our
missteps is coming to a community and saying, "This is what matters, and this is
what we should be doing." Rather, it should be the other way around.
I
just got my R01. I've been working with Can Community Health, which is an HIV
clinic, for the past four years,
talking to providers, talking to staff, doing surveys of
patients to understand where are the gaps, what do they care about.
Do they care about cancer prevention? Yes, they did, thankfully.
And so moving that
forward was a process of engagement and conversations
over time, and also building that relationship and building trust.
So ensuring that your setting or your partners
prioritize the topic is key. Otherwise, like
you're saying, it's going to fail, right?
If you don't have buy-in, if you don't have those sustainment
objectives overarching your project,
then it's not going to go anywhere.
Yeah. I would agree with that as well.
I think the other piece is that
is really attending to the relationship and
understanding that people like
aren't unmotivated. I would say that the
clinical sites were very engaged with how they could improve this
but they were also really realistic because they understood the resource
constraints, the very real resource constraints that they operate
under. And, I think what we could
change on a macro level is actually just
giving more voice, because primary care is underfunded in
traditional primary care, but it's
very under-resourced for the people who have the greatest need.
And so,
I'm
always impressed with how much they are able to do,
and really think of the work that we do
as, in order to get buy-in, you have to bring
something to the table that matters for the care that they care
about. And I think learning what that is, is a
thing that requires relationship building.
And even for the sites that didn't participate in the implementation,
I disseminated the toolkit at the end after our implementation was
over,
to all of the sites that participated in the implementation planning, because I
wanted them to feel like this product was theirs, not mine,
because it would have never been developed without their input.
We're going to move on to one more mic, and then there's an online one, and then
we'll try to get to the last one. It's okay. You don't have to walk away.
I'll try to get you.
I'll come faster.
Okay.
I'll try to make as brief as possible.
So, Bruno Duzer from Gustave Roussy in Paris.
So I think it's a couple questions.
One is probably a development of what was already asked.
We have the opportunity to work in a very
niche context, which is a tertiary environment with a
specific center for early detection and prevention.
And one of the missing links specifically are the GPs that have the
lowest level of responses to the initiatives that are produced within the
institution. So, question is, do you have a nice magic recipe
to motivate GPs to engage within the projects?
Because otherwise, we have to announce and make advertising of the programs,
online flyers, and some old school ways that I think would
not be ideal. So that's the first question.
The second one is from a translational perspective.
When we develop the assays or develop drugs to be potentially introduced in the
clinics,
we always think about PPV, NPV, to move from the
population of highest benefit to the overall. So scaling up.
Mm-hmm.
Apart from those specific metrics, do you have key
things that we can forecast in the first place when we try to
upscale from the niche population to the highest benefit, high-risk
population to the overall population? So those are the two questions.
So,
I would probably think about the question that you're asking is how do we go from
these very specific high-risk population groups to scaling up.
And I almost think that at least in our study on HPV
vaccination, we experienced what it
was like for implementation and implementation
strategies to try to support
larger integrated systems like Kaiser,
like large integrated health systems, other large primary
care practices of privately insured populations.
And our study landed at less was done in
FQHC settings. And so, sort of the broad
population had been tried to be tackled,
over the first 15 years of the vaccine being introduced.
And we were not seeing increasing rates, right?
I would say,
one aspect about implementation science and maybe across all of our cancer centers
is that we work very closely with our community outreach and engagement
programs, because a lot of where we identify who we target and who we
partner with has to do with where is the burden
of cancer greatest or where are the
disparities in our region. And so it really is more driven,
probably in a combination of burden in the
area, active partners, and then the ability to do
something because an organization is ready to do something.
Mm-hmm.
Is kind of aligned with the
continuation of the prior question.
And your first question about GPs, how do we motivate them?
Great question. It really depends on the
context that you're working in.
For example, in the United States, there are FQHCs that have
specific metrics that they need to meet,
or targets that they have to meet in order to receive funding from
CMS and in order to
be rated highly. And it
impacts the money that they receive essentially or services that they receive.
So in those settings, physicians are highly motivated to
reach targets of these different metrics, they're called UDS metrics,
in order to ensure that their clinic is receiving
or meeting the standards and the targets that have been set.
So I think when you think about GPs or individuals, you
have to think about the structure or the system that they're working within and
think about it from a multilevel perspective of, okay, in order
to motivate the individual, how do I set up the structure or the
system so that the individual can do what
they themselves want to do? They became
GPs because they're interested in preventative service delivery and caring for
people and ensuring that everybody gets their cancer prevention and whatnot.
So we know that it matters to them. That's their whole career.
But how do we set up the structure of the system so that they're incentivized or
that they're rewarded, right, for doing what they
became GPs to do. Yeah
Only one to piggyback on Dr. Islam's comment is also I
focus often on the entirety of the practice staff, not just the
individual clinician, because most of our implementation
requires-- it's a team sport.
But I do think that the clinical relevance
of the question that you're asking is key, but I think the
readiness of the practice is also key.
So one of the challenges in implementation science is being
able to partner with practices who are ready to commit to an
implementation. And that is a challenge,
and the biggest challenge within that,
I found during the recruitment, was staff turnover.
When we transitioned from that
identification of the implementation strategy to
digging into what the barriers are, that was the most
consistent barrier for every single one of them.
And I think it's the knowledge transfer and the
constant burden of a system that's working with less people than it needs,
then training people to pick it up, and then they leave, and then more
people leave. And it's a revolving door that they described
that got bad during COVID and has stayed bad.
Last question from online, and then we'll get to you
in person if we have some.
Thank you for those of you who have been online this whole time.
We can't see your faces, but we'll imagine.
This is a question actually for Dr. O'Malley.
This individual online asked, "If I wanted to
copy what you did as a starting point for increasing colorectal
cancer screening in higher risk individuals, like with
diabetes, and then adapt the work to fit my local
context, how would I go about it?"
Good question.
Yeah.
That's an excellent question. So I think what you would do would
be to
look at the toolkit, which is the resource of
all the materials, the resources that the practices said that they
needed. And then we used
practice transformation facilitators to meet with
each individual practice and talk about
what change strategy did they want to implement, and then we adapted the
tools to match the change that they planned on implementing.
So it's a
goal setting for the individual objective of the practice based on the
resources available to them, adapting the resources
that we made available to fit the needs of their change
strategy, and then supporting them by thinking through the
different pieces. So that
sheet that I handed out, that I demonstrated, which was
like, who needs to change what at the planning phase?
What change do you want to make? Who needs to
do what to make that change? And what are the barriers or facilitators?
That can be done
using the toolkit as well, and you can think about the
resources in the toolkit as things that can be brought
forth to address specific goals and
barriers.
I think with that, we'll conclude our session.
Thanks for staying till 6:15 on a Friday.
Yes.
See you around.
Oh, good job, guys.
We did it.
So much to pack in one-